congrats on being on season 41 of
survivor you were incredible you played
such a great game listen things did not
turn out as you had hoped i would
imagine but what are the emotions that
you're feeling this morning
oh man i i honestly like it is like a
lot of emotions you know i i wasn't
expecting it quite as much because i was
like this happened months ago but you
know watching it back it really does get
you again and honestly like the
overwhelming feeling i do feel is just
like pride like i went out there and i
had three goals you know like have fun
get to play and like represent queer
people as well as i could and like i
really really feel like i accomplished
all three of those so you know how mad
can i be you know you definitely did you
accomplished all three of those goals
you know it's a weird thing to watch
yourself back i do this for a living i'm
not even used to it yet myself so what
was the experience of watching yourself
back on survivor
yeah honestly it was so fun like i think
you know you and matt when i was out
there i was always imagining like wow
this is going to be on survivor you know
and then you watch your back and it's
like that's me playing survivor like i i
i'm playing you know and you know i'm
really grateful for the show like i
think they i feel like they represented
me really well i felt like i came off
like me and that was like so important
to me so i it was honestly really fun to
watch it back uh and there wasn't too
much where i was like well i can't think
that person said that about me you know
i pretty much knew uh knew what was
going on so uh no it's honestly been a
really fun experience and just you know
it's kind of like you went to summer
camp but then someone filmed it and put
it on tv like i get to be like to my
partner like look that's where i slept
and like that's the you know that's my
friend so you know it's been fun to
watch back
awesome listen you said something before
you left any queer kids out there be
yourself you're amazing love yourself
that is such a powerful per uh statement
to hear from a queer person did you feel
a little bit of pressure you know
representing the queer community
yeah i mean to some degree you know i
did feel pressure but it was also a
really special thing that i wasn't the
only queer person there like there were
three queer people on the season and
like we're all really different and have
kind of different stories so i think
that's one of the coolest things about
this season is like when you have a
really diverse cast every one person
doesn't have to be the representative of
like all the
you know all people so i think that's
really cool and special and you know for
me it's like i think just being there
and like presenting the way i do and
like you know wearing freaking rainbow
underwear and bow tie like i think that
would have been cool enough but like to
go out there and
to me the most important thing is like
everyone liked me you know what i mean
it wasn't like i was the queer kid who
was like the loser on the side it's like
everyone was wanted to work with me like
that was my you know arc and then i went
on to like you know make strategic moves
and win a challenge and like all that
and so it's honestly more than i could
ever hope for and i've honestly received
like the most moving like feedback from
especially like queer audience members
or parents of queer kids and things like
that and that's absolutely absolutely
the best thing i could have ever asked
for so i'm proud of it
you should be so proud they obviously
all liked you there but they clearly saw
you as a threat and that is why you are
here today would you have changed
anything about your gameplay
i mean number one i would have pulled
the yellow rock at uh this last uh vote
because i think that was really the
fatal flaw in my game uh but honestly i
can't say i would change too much like i
think going into the game i was hoping
that i could have been under the radar
for longer but i didn't have that option
because i was on yasa and we were losing
every challenge at the beginning and so
i knew that like if i didn't take over
that situation i very well would have
been the second person to go like it
would have been so easy like tiff evie
done you know and so i had to like play
an out in front game a little bit more
than i was expecting because that's the
reality of a six try game and you know
then the merge comes and bam like this
hourglass twist happens and again like
all the focus is on me kind of like
arbitrarily and so i i think a lot of
the things that put me in that situation
were not my own doing necessarily but
you know i played the game that i had to
play to get to as far as they did so i
really can't complain about anything
this was honestly one of the best
seasons of survivor in
a while and i can say that and i think
it's because there were so many
different personalities first and
foremost representation is there but
beyond that the twists in this season
were like
is there a twist that blew your mind the
most
i mean the twist that blew my mind the
most i always assumed and maybe this is
naive i always assume that survivor
operated under linear time but that's
not true anymore you know survivor can
go backwards they can go forwards who
knows what else they could do so that
absolutely blew my mind i never saw that
coming i thought that if jeff said you
have immunity you have immunity uh but
you know that is the game of survivor
you have to be adaptable you have to be
able to like get out of any situation
and uh you know i got myself out of two
incredibly tricky situations and it was
on the third that i got killed so you
know
it is what it is but yeah this is a
fantastic cast and it is because of the
diversity and like when you have people
with all different stories stories that
haven't been seen on the show again
multiple of like each quote-unquote
archetype you know there that just makes
it so much more interesting and cool and
special and like i was just so so
freaking honored to get to be part of
this particular cast so great season
it's a great cast expect the unexpected
listen how the heck can nobody get shan
out and what is it gonna take like what
you have no idea i was so hoping that we
were gonna walk into that tribal and see
shane sitting on the jury like that was
my dream and you know kudos to her it
didn't happen she's a great player you
know and she's got an idol in her pocket
so uh you know
we'll see what happens but
she's good
yeah i mean and i think the reality is
like
yeah
we will end that there so listen a
two-part question for you because i
think they're gonna be different answers
so after spending time with all these
castaways who would you want to win
season 41 of survivor and who do you
think will win
season 41
like who would win this season
who wants you okay well um
you know like tiffany really for me is
like family like i think you saw a lot
of our relationship in the game and now
seeing like then we got to spend all
this time at ponderosa together like
there was only 24 hours of the entire
game that we weren't together so if it
had to be someone else i would
definitely give it to tiff and she's a
mom and has like she's she's an
absolutely wonderful wonderful person so
if i could pick anyone to win
it would be tiff but uh i can't tell you
who i think would win i mean come on you
just gotta watch the season
oh come on that is a pageant answer but
that's okay so many people in the office
are telling me to ask you
how the heck you kept your glasses on
for all of the challenges how did they
stay on
okay but there's a secret that if you
now that you know you can look for it i
was actually had a strap on on the back
of my glasses and it was so funny
because my partner made so much fun of
me because i ordered like 17 different
straps beforehand and i was like
testing all that was like what about
this one what about this one with this
one but it was so crucial and like yeah
i could like dive in the water with that
strap on and my glasses stayed on so i'm
proud of it i mean it didn't help keep
the glasses clean like before everything
before every confessional they're just
like can you try to wipe it so we can
see your eyes at all
[Music]
would you come back and do it all again
if you were asked
absolutely hell yeah i would go back and
play again like i have unfinished
business out there and i would
absolutely love to play again but uh i
feel like my game was a little exposed
so i don't know how far i would actually
get but i would love to give it a go
well i would love to see you on there
again congrats though you were a
fantastic player you had such a great
time loved watching you and can't wait
to see what's next doctor for you
thank you so much i appreciate it